Tại vì tiền định biến, sợi vường của bưa lưỡn kéo sài trong nhiều mẹ qua,
thành nhiều địa phương của tiền đã rất hiện lũ ở nụ phép.
Tình địa đình mởi bột lợi sáng nay,
mở lũ lặng vui bụng người chết mất tích và bị thương.
Trong gạo có mởi hành người chết và mất tích,
hành người bị thương nhiều tài sàng của người dân bị thiệt hại.
Một số khu dân cứ bị câu lợp hoàn toàn.
Tại vì bùng gạo sàng dung là địa bàn triệu dự khi thại nhất để người.
Theo đó, mở lũ đả lặng bụng người chết,
hành người bị thương to lũ của chơi,
sống người bị bụng lắp trước tình thể thiệt.
Tại sạch tiền dình đã sạch lợi từ dự hích đã bụi lắp nhà của bụng thậu dân.
Sợ việc thảy ra trong đêm khiến sạm định không kịp chở tay.
Hậu hoàn làm chết hành người, nước lũ cũng cũng quân chơi một người dân của sáng.
Tình định bụng mở lợi sáng nay, mừng một tháng tắm,
trên địa phản tình nghiệp biệt có một chân hay biết tảm nhà dân bị anh lượng gói lũ.
Trong đó, chỉ nghĩ bệnh nhà gặp lụt,
mời bộn nhà sạch lợi, mời bệnh nhà bị lụt của chơi bối lấp.
Ngay sâu hyss thảy ra thiền tay, chính quyền địa phương đã hình chương vì đồng lực tại chỗ trên khai ương cưỡng.
Bánh chỉ vì phòng thổ khu vực bán nà sòn đã khi đồng con bộ lực lượng phương tiệt cơ đồng ứng cưỡng.
Bộ chỉ vì quân sự tình đã khi đồng hợt bà chăm bán bi cán bộ chiến sĩ,
ra đại tảng, quyền tiền lòng, phó chỉ vì chưởng bộ chỉ vì quân sự tình chức tiếp chỉ vì ứng phó khắc phục hậu hoàn thiền tay.
Hẹn đại hầu hết các tuyền tuần bị sản lợi giống ngưu, các khu vực bị chiếc cắt,
câu lập, nền việc tiếp tận hiện chương trị phai cú hậu tụ nạn sất khó khăn.